This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. In October 2014, Psychology Professor Nancy Siegel heard a story. It was about her specialty, the study of twins. Nancy had made a career of studying unusual cases of twins, but she had never heard a story like this one. It's December 1988. A woman from a remote farming village in Colombia makes a day-long trek to a hospital. She gives birth there to a pair of identical twin boys.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。2014年10月，心理学教授南希·西格尔听到了一个故事。故事关于她的专业领域——双胞胎研究。南希职业生涯中研究过许多罕见的双胞胎案例，但她从未听过这样的故事。时间回到1988年12月。哥伦比亚一个偏远农村的一名妇女，跋涉了一整天来到医院。她在那里生下了一对同卵双胞胎男孩。
One of the twins needs more advanced medical care that isn't available. One of them was extremely sick. Since the mom is still recuperating, a relative takes him to another hospital, six hours away in Bogota, the capital. At the Bogota Hospital, another set of identical twin boys has just been born. Their mother is a seamstress who lives in the city. The scene was quite chaotic. The hospital staff is tired and overworked.
其中一个双胞胎需要更先进的医疗护理，但当地没有。其中一个病得非常重。由于母亲还在恢复期，一位亲戚带着他去了六小时路程外的首都波哥大的另一家医院。在波哥大的那家医院，刚好也出生了一对同卵双胞胎男孩。他们的母亲是一位住在城里的裁缝。当时现场非常混乱。医院工作人员既疲惫又超负荷工作。
It was approaching Christmas time. People were thinking about the holidays. Now, nobody knows exactly what happens next, but something goes wrong. The baby from the countryside is switched with one of the babies born to the mother from the city. By the time all the babies are sent home, one boy from each pair of identical twins is in the wrong family. Each family thinks their twins are fraternal. The homes the boys grow up in are in totally different places, 150 miles away from each
当时临近圣诞节。人们都在想着过节的事。现在，没人确切知道接下来发生了什么，但出了差错。来自农村的婴儿与来自城里的母亲所生的婴儿之一被调换了。当所有婴儿被送回家时，每对同卵双胞胎中都有一个男孩被送到了错误的家庭。每个家庭都以为他们的双胞胎是异卵的。男孩们长大的地方完全不同，相距150英里，
other, and a world apart. One the lively capital city of Bogota, and the other in a very remote farming village, and they'd had no modern amenities, no schooling, things of that sort. Researchers who studied twins knew of many examples of identical twins raised apart. But two sets of identical twins, where one from each pair was switched into the other home, it had never been documented before. It brought up fascinating questions. 25 years later, when the truth was discovered, Nancy says it was also deeply painful.
彼此之间，简直是天壤之别。一个在繁华的首都波哥大，另一个在非常偏远的农村，那里没有现代设施，没有学校，诸如此类。研究双胞胎的学者知道许多同卵双胞胎分开抚养的例子。但两对同卵双胞胎，每对中各有一个被换到了另一个家庭，这在以前从未被记录过。这引出了引人入胜的问题。25年后，当真相被发现时，南希说这也令人深感痛苦。
It was also a tragedy in the sense that two of the twins grew up in a home where they were not biologically connected, and they discovered in a matter of minutes that their identities were totally shattered. They weren't to their thought they were, they belonged in other families, their parents were not their parents. In short, everything about their life was basically a line. This week we'll delve into the story of the Bogota twins, a tragedy, a soap opera, and a science experiment all rolled into one. And we'll also find out why twin studies can act as a natural experiment to test some of the biggest questions about human nature.
从某种意义上说，这也是一场悲剧，因为其中两个双胞胎在没有血缘关系的家庭中长大，他们在几分钟内发现自己的身份完全破碎了。他们不是他们以为的那样，他们属于其他家庭，他们的父母不是他们的父母。简而言之，他们生活的一切基本上都是谎言。本周，我们将深入探讨波哥大双胞胎的故事，这是一个集悲剧、肥皂剧和科学实验于一体的故事。我们还将了解为什么双胞胎研究可以作为一种自然实验，来测试关于人性的一些重大问题。
How much of our lives is shaped by upbringing? How much by genes? Are we the masters of our own fate? Or are we all destined to become our mothers? Insights and provocations from two in-studies this week on Hidden Brain. Nancy Siegel is a professor of psychology at California State University, Fulitan. She is the director of that twin study center. She wrote about the Bogota twins in her book, Accidental Brothers, The Story of Twins Exchanged at Birth, and the power of nature and nurture.
我们的生活有多少是由教养塑造的？有多少是由基因决定的？我们是自己命运的主宰吗？还是我们注定要成为我们的母亲？本周在《隐藏的大脑》中，我们将从双胞胎研究中获得见解和启发。南希·西格尔是加州州立大学富勒顿分校的心理学教授。她是该双胞胎研究中心的主任。她在她的书《意外的兄弟：出生时被交换的双胞胎的故事，以及先天与后天的力量》中写到了波哥大双胞胎。
In both the remote farming village and the city, each set of mismatched brothers had very different outlooks and personalities. In each family, one brother seemed outgoing, the other reserved. And in fact, people would kid the twins and the parents and say, are you sure your twins? And how could you have two boys look so different? But people again are sensitive to fraternal twin differences. People know that ordinary siblings and a family who have the same genetic relatedness as fraternal twins often look and act very differently.
在偏远的农村和城市里，每对错位的兄弟都有着非常不同的性格和人生观。在每个家庭中，一个兄弟似乎外向，另一个内向。事实上，人们会开玩笑地问双胞胎和父母，你们确定是双胞胎吗？你们怎么会有两个长相如此不同的男孩？但人们对异卵双胞胎的差异很敏感。人们知道，家庭中拥有相同遗传相关性的普通兄弟姐妹，看起来和表现往往也非常不同。
So it was not such a tremendous surprise. The other interesting thing though is that in Bogota, the mom had been told she was having identical twins, and this might have been information gotten from an early scan as possible. But it could be that, you know, sometimes these things can be unreliable, and so when she had fraternal twin boys,
所以这并不算太大的意外。不过另一个有趣的事情是，在波哥大，那位母亲被告知她怀的是同卵双胞胎，这可能是从早期扫描中获得的信息。但也有可能，你知道，有时这些事情可能不可靠，所以当她生下异卵双胞胎男孩时，
she accepted it and was quite pleased. William and Wilbur, the two brothers who grew up in the farming village, eventually moved to Bogota and get jobs behind the counter at a butcher shop. It's the summer of 2013, they're now 25. And it's here where their lives begin to intersect with the brothers in the city, Jorge and Carlos, where it starts to become clear that someone, somehow, has made a terrible mistake. A coworker of Jorge, again, one of the twins raised in the city,
她接受了，并且非常高兴。威廉和威尔伯，这对在农村长大的兄弟，最终搬到了波哥大，在一家肉铺柜台后面找到了工作。那是2013年的夏天，他们现在25岁了。正是在这里，他们的生活开始与城里的兄弟豪尔赫和卡洛斯产生交集，也正是在这里，事情开始变得清晰：有人，以某种方式，犯了一个可怕的错误。豪尔赫的一位同事，也就是在城里长大的双胞胎之一，
runs into William at the Buche Shop. One day, two women went to the Butcher Shop to buy some meat. Now, one of those women was a coworker of Jorge's. And her first impulse was, what is Jorge doing behind the Butcher counter? Is he moonlighting as a Butcher on weekends as he's short of money? And she was really baffled when he didn't greet her. Meanwhile, the friend that she was with said, don't be silly, that is my boyfriend's cousin. So they're going back and forth, back and forth on this.
在肉铺遇到了威廉。有一天，两名妇女去肉铺买肉。其中一名妇女是豪尔赫的同事。她的第一反应是，豪尔赫在肉铺柜台后面干什么？他周末缺钱在做兼职屠夫吗？当他没有向她打招呼时，她真的感到很困惑。与此同时，她身边的朋友说，别傻了，那是我男朋友的表弟。所以她们就这个问题反复争论。
And finally, he said, my name is William, I'm her boyfriend's cousin, I don't know Jorge, and that was it. But when Laura, this friend, went back to see Jorge the following week at work, she told him about it, they had a good laugh about it, and nothing really happened. But something about the incident sticks with Laura. She tracks down a photo of William and brings it to Jorge's desk. She tells him to sit down, he's about to be shocked. Jorge stares at the image on Laura's phone.
最后，他说，我叫威廉，我是她男朋友的表弟，我不认识豪尔赫，事情就是这样。但当劳拉，也就是那位朋友，下周回到工作岗位见到豪尔赫时，她告诉了他这件事，他们对此大笑了一场，并没有真正发生什么。但这件事的某些地方让劳拉耿耿于怀。她找出一张威廉的照片，带到了豪尔赫的办公桌前。她让他坐下，他即将受到惊吓。豪尔赫盯着劳拉手机上的图像。
He swears, that's me, he says. One thing leads to another, and the two biological brothers meet for the first time, at a public square in Bogota. The scene is captured on someone's phone. A friend, off screen, sounds shocked.
他发誓，那就是我，他说。一件事接着另一件事，这对亲生兄弟在波哥大的一个公共广场第一次见面。这一幕被某人的手机拍了下来。屏幕外的一位朋友听起来很震惊。
Jorge and William look exactly the same. Another friend breaks the ice. William is wider, he says. But other than their complexion, they are like mirror images. Both handsome with delicate features. Both have an easy laugh. They steal glances at each other and shift from side to side. Oh my God says their friend. This can be true.
豪尔赫和威廉长得一模一样。另一位朋友打破了僵局。威廉更宽一些，他说。但除了肤色，他们就像镜子里的影像。两人都长相英俊，五官精致。两人都有爽朗的笑声。他们偷看对方，左右摇摆。天哪，他们的朋友说。这怎么可能。
Jorge says I can't believe it. To an onlooker, this moment would look like nothing. Just young men joking around. It's meaning would sink in only later. I'm so glad to have you here. But right now, they have so many questions. William and Jorge go to a nearby coffee shop where they find they have instant chemistry. They got along well. They understood the world the same way.
豪尔赫说我不敢相信。对于旁观者来说，这一刻看起来没什么特别。只是年轻人在开玩笑。它的意义只有后来才会显现。我很高兴见到你。但现在，他们有太多的问题。威廉和豪尔赫去了附近的一家咖啡馆，发现他们之间有瞬间的化学反应。他们相处得很好。他们以同样的方式理解世界。
And that was something rare for them because neither one of them shared it with their fraternal twin, they're so called fraternal twin brother. Up next would be the reunion of the other identical twin pair, Carlos and Wilbur. And here's something I've left out of the story. Wilbur was also at the square that night, watching from the sidelines. It was decided then and there that he should meet his identical twin Carlos as soon as possible. The three young men get in a cab to go find Carlos. The reunion is hard for Carlos. It meant he was supposed to have grown up on a farm, not a city.
这对他们来说是罕见的，因为他们都没有与他们的异卵双胞胎，也就是所谓的异卵双胞胎兄弟分享过这种感觉。接下来是另一对同卵双胞胎卡洛斯和威尔伯的重聚。这里有一件事我没讲。那天晚上威尔伯也在广场，在场边观看。当时就决定他应该尽快见到他的同卵双胞胎卡洛斯。这三个年轻人打了一辆出租车去寻找卡洛斯。重聚对卡洛斯来说很艰难。这意味着他本应该在农场长大，而不是在城市。
It meant his brother was not his real brother. His sister was not his real sister. His mother was not his real mother. Because you've got to remember that Carlos was a city boy. He loved his mother who would pass away a few years earlier and to discover that she might not be his mother was absolutely devastating to him. The first time he saw his identical brother Wilbur, Carlos went out of his way to try and
这意味着他的兄弟不是他真正的兄弟。他的姐妹不是他真正的姐妹。他的母亲不是他真正的母亲。因为你必须记住，卡洛斯是个城市男孩。他深爱着几年前去世的母亲，发现她可能不是自己的亲生母亲对他来说是绝对毁灭性的打击。他第一次见到同卵兄弟威尔伯时，卡洛斯竭尽全力试图
find differences between them. But he looked in vain because they looked exactly the same. Both of them were very, very interested in appearance. Both of them got their eyebrows waxed, very into fashion. They both, like similar types of girlfriends. They both called themselves the cry babies because they were very sensitive as children. They were always complaining and always kind of undergoing various medical complaints. Whereas Jorge and William had no medical complaints whatsoever. We gave them long medical histories and Jorge and William
找出他们之间的差异。但他徒劳无功，因为他们长得一模一样。他们俩都对外观非常感兴趣。他们俩都修眉毛，非常时尚。他们都喜欢相似类型的女朋友。他们都称自己为爱哭鬼，因为他们小时候非常敏感。他们总是抱怨，总是患有各种各样的医疗问题。而豪尔赫和威廉没有任何医疗问题。我们给了他们长长的病史记录，豪尔赫和威廉
just handed them in blank. But Carlos and Wilbur had long lists of various types of pains and aches and other ailments. Did the brothers stay in touch after the mix-up was corrected and revealed? Oh, yes. In fact, they call themselves, well, I call them the band of brothers because they do that. And they had stayed in touch. They make decisions based on four. They have a common email address. They really are very close
只是交了白卷。但卡洛斯和威尔伯有长长的各种疼痛、酸痛和其他疾病的清单。在错误被纠正和揭露后，兄弟们还保持联系吗？哦，是的。事实上，他们称自己为，嗯，我称他们为兄弟连，因为他们确实如此。他们一直保持联系。他们基于四个人做出决定。他们有一个共同的电子邮件地址。他们确实非常亲密，
and you know what's important is that there are two ways they could have handled this. One would have been complete despair and the other is simply accepting and moving on. And so they and their family members say, look, we did not lose an nephew, we did not lose a brother, we did not lose a son, we're gaining. And I think that they should be applauded for that kind of an attitude and for carrying it out so successfully. As a researcher, obviously, you've been fascinated by how the bonds of genetic connection might prompt similarities. But when you went out to Bogota, did you also find that the bonds of familial connection, growing up in the same household, growing up in the same environment, did that form or forge connections that are also still apparent today?
你知道重要的是，他们有两种处理方式。一种是彻底绝望，另一种是简单地接受并继续生活。所以他们和他们的家人说，看，我们没有失去一个侄子，没有失去一个兄弟，没有失去一个儿子，我们是在获得。我认为他们那种态度以及成功地执行这种态度应该受到赞扬。作为一名研究人员，显然，你一直对遗传联系的纽带如何促成相似性感到着迷。但当你去波哥大时，你是否也发现家庭联系的纽带，在同一个家庭中长大，在同一个环境中长大，是否也形成了今天仍然明显的联系？
Yes, each pair of unrelated brothers feels a tremendous loyalty toward the other one. So Jorge wanted initially, if perhaps Carlos would feel left out, and so he went and got a tattoo of Carlos on his chest next to the one he has of his mother and in Spanish it says my sacred family and that was very touching for Carlos. So they maintained a lot of family loyalty as do William and Wilbur. Now William and Wilbur were in the army together. They were in the army together, they went to Bolivia together and they washed out for one another, a great deal when they're there and of course they worked together for many years in that butcher shop.
是的，每一对没有血缘关系的兄弟对另一方都有着巨大的忠诚。所以豪尔赫最初担心卡洛斯是否会感到被冷落，于是他去胸前纹了一个卡洛斯的纹身，就在他母亲纹身的旁边，上面用西班牙语写着我的神圣家庭，这对卡洛斯来说非常感人。所以他们保持了很强的家庭忠诚度，威廉和威尔伯也是如此。现在威廉和威尔伯曾一起在军队服役。他们一起在军队里，一起去了玻利维亚，他们在那里非常照顾对方，当然，他们在那个肉铺一起工作了很多年。
So the loyalties are there, but at the same time the twins will tell you that there is disagreement, there is animosity, there is friction, and they don't have that immediate understanding with the unrelated brother that they so quickly forged with the related brother when they met for just a short time. You've studied a number of other twins. Twins raised together, twins raised apart, identical twins, fraternal twins. We'll talk about the science of twin research in the second half of our conversation and what this means in terms of parenting and other issues.
所以忠诚度是存在的，但与此同时，双胞胎会告诉你，会有分歧，会有敌意，会有摩擦，他们与没有血缘关系的兄弟之间没有那种他们与有血缘关系的兄弟见面时迅速建立的那种即时理解。你研究过许多其他双胞胎。一起长大的双胞胎，分开长大的双胞胎，同卵双胞胎，异卵双胞胎。我们将在对话的后半部分讨论双胞胎研究的科学，以及这对育儿和其他问题意味着什么。
But I want to look at a couple of other examples first. Tell me about the Jim twins. Well, the Jim twins, Jim Lewis and Jim Springer, were identical twins born in Ohio and grew up about 30, 40 miles apart. And they met when they were 39 years old. One of the families had been told the other twin had died, but she later learned that was not the case. And the twins eventually decided it was time to meet, and they did.
但我先想看另外几个例子。跟我说说吉姆双胞胎。嗯，吉姆双胞胎，吉姆·刘易斯和吉姆·斯普林格，是出生在俄亥俄州的同卵双胞胎，在相距约30到40英里的地方长大。他们在39岁时相遇。其中一个家庭被告知另一个双胞胎已经去世，但她后来得知事实并非如此。双胞胎最终决定是时候见面了，他们确实见面了。
What is all the meeting exactly down there? You may have heard or read about my next guest. In 1979, just a few months after the twins first met, they shared their story on the tonight show starring Johnny Carson. Please Jim Lewis and Jim Springer. The similarities were incredible. Jim's been married three times.
那次见面到底是怎么回事？你可能听说过或读过我的下一位嘉宾。1979年，就在双胞胎第一次见面几个月后，他们在约翰尼·卡森主持的《今夜秀》上分享了他们的故事。请欢迎吉姆·刘易斯和吉姆·斯普林格。相似之处令人难以置信。吉姆结过三次婚。
They've been married twice. His first wife, named the same as mine. His first wife is the same name as yours. They both married different women named Linda. They both divorced them and married women named Betty. And then one of the Jim twins divorced Betty and married Sandy. And so I imagine that Betty is all nervous waiting in the wings to see what's going to happen. And we both named her first son, Sam, James Allen.
他们结过两次婚。他的第一任妻子的名字和我的名字一样。他的第一任妻子的名字和你的名字一样。他们都娶了不同的名叫琳达的女人。他们都和她们离婚，然后娶了名叫贝蒂的女人。然后其中一个吉姆双胞胎和贝蒂离婚，娶了桑迪。所以我猜贝蒂现在正紧张地在后台等着看会发生什么。我们都给第一个儿子取名山姆，詹姆斯·艾伦。
And we both named her dog's toy. And both of them had light blue Chevrolet's. They both liked the vacation on the same three-block strip of beach in Florida. And it's amazing they didn't meet there. They both used to bite their fingernails. They both used to scatter love letters around the house to their wives. And they both enjoyed woodworking. So their similarities went on for a long time.
我们都给狗的玩具取了名字。他们俩都有浅蓝色的雪佛兰。他们都喜欢在佛罗里达同一片三街区长的海滩上度假。令人惊讶的是他们没有在那里相遇。他们都习惯咬指甲。他们都习惯在家里给妻子散布情书。他们都喜欢木工。所以他们的相似之处持续了很长时间。
And what's interesting is that they were the ones who first launched the Minnesota study of twins raised apart, directed by Professor Thomas Bouchard at the University of Minnesota. And this pair got so much attention that other pairs suddenly came out of the woodwork. And before Bouchard knew it, he had 15 pairs in the list. Now, of course, when you're a researcher and you're studying twins like this, it's difficult to distinguish between things that are actually points of connection and things that are coincidences. In other words, the fact they both married a woman named Linda might be a coincidence. It might have nothing to do with the fact they're identical twins.
有趣的是，他们是第一批启动明尼苏达州分开抚养双胞胎研究的人，该研究由明尼苏达大学的托马斯·布查德教授指导。这对双胞胎受到了如此多的关注，以至于其他双胞胎突然从各个角落冒了出来。在布查德意识到之前，他的名单上已经有15对双胞胎了。当然，当你是一名研究人员并研究这样的双胞胎时，很难区分哪些是真正的联系点，哪些是巧合。换句话说，他们都娶了一个名叫琳达的女人可能是一个巧合。这可能与他们是同卵双胞胎的事实无关。
How do you go about distinguishing between those two things, telling the things that are coincidences from the things that you think actually are driven by some form of connection. Yeah, well, first of all, let's say that maybe being attracted to women with a certain name is not random. We don't know that for sure. But the way we can distinguish coincidence from real scientific hard data that's got a genetic basis is that you compare identical twins with fraternal twins with reference to a particular attribute. Now, we had different kinds of quirky habits that we would see in some identical pairs. So for example, one of the identical pairs
你是如何区分这两件事的，把巧合的事情与你认为实际上是由某种联系驱动的事情区分开来？是的，嗯，首先，让我们说，被名字特定的女性吸引可能不是随机的。我们不能确定。但我们可以将巧合与具有遗传基础的真实科学硬数据区分开来的方法是，参考特定属性比较同卵双胞胎和异卵双胞胎。现在，我们在一些同卵双胞胎中看到了不同种类的古怪习惯。例如，其中一对同卵双胞胎
always read books from back to front. And another identical pair, both twins used to scratch their ears with paper clips. So you can't start looking for paper clips scratching across pairs or for reading books back to front. What you can look for are matched unusual habits. And if you find matched unusual habits more often in identical twins, then you do infertional
总是从后往前读书。另一对同卵双胞胎，两个双胞胎都习惯用回形针抓耳朵。所以你不能开始寻找跨对的回形针抓挠或从后往前读书的行为。你可以寻找的是匹配的不寻常习惯。如果你在同卵双胞胎中发现匹配的不寻常习惯的频率高于在异卵双胞胎中，
twins. This gives you some clue that the genes may be driving that behavior at least in part. You looked at another pair of twins who had some remarkable things in common, including some of the behaviors you just described. Tell me about the Giggle twins. Oh, the Giggle twins. They were from Great Britain. And when they met for the first time, they discovered that with each other, but with nobody
那么这给你一些线索，基因可能至少在一定程度上驱动了这种行为。你研究了另一对双胞胎，他们有一些显著的共同点，包括你刚才描述的一些行为。跟我说说咯咯笑双胞胎。哦，咯咯笑双胞胎。她们来自英国。当她们第一次见面时，她们发现彼此之间，但与其他人
else, they would giggle uncontrollably. They even did this to me once on a TV set, which was really irking the producers. But there was something about the other one that just set them off. But they also had other similarities in that, besides their identical appearance, they both had the same crooked pinky fingers. They both just liked the politics. They both had a habit of wrinkling their nose, something they both called squidging. So they had a number of similarities as well.
不同，她们会无法控制地咯咯笑。她们甚至在电视节目中对我这样做过一次，这让制片人非常恼火。但对方身上确实有些东西让她们停不下来。但她们还有其他相似之处，除了她们相同的长相，她们都有同样弯曲的小指。她们都喜欢政治。她们都有皱鼻子的习惯，她们俩都称之为挤压。所以她们也有许多相似之处。
But we called them the giggle twins because that was their hallmark feature. After the break, the science of twin studies and what they can tell us about the mysterious serious dance between nature and nurture. Nancy researchers long ago had an insight. Some twins are fraternal and some twins are identical. What is the genetic difference between such twins? And how do you and other scientists use these differences in what are called twin studies? Identical twins result when a single fertilized egg divides sometime between the first and 14th day after conception.
但我们称她们为咯咯笑双胞胎，因为那是她们的标志性特征。休息后，双胞胎研究的科学，以及它们能告诉我们关于先天与后天之间神秘舞蹈的信息。南希，研究人员很久以前就有一个见解。有些双胞胎是异卵的，有些是同卵的。这种双胞胎之间的遗传差异是什么？你和其他科学家是如何在所谓的双胞胎研究中使用这些差异的？同卵双胞胎产生于单个受精卵在受孕后第1天到第14天之间的某个时间分裂。
So these twins share other genes in common and are always of the same sex. For turnal twins result when a woman releases two eggs at the same time and they are separately fertilized by two sperm from the father. So these twins share half the genes on average just like ordinary brothers and sisters. So what we do is as scientists, we gather large numbers of both types of pairs, and we compare the similarities with respect to intelligence, personality, running speed, interests, food preferences, and in virtually every study that I've seen, identical twins tend to be more like than fraternal twins,
所以这些双胞胎拥有相同的基因，并且总是性别相同。异卵双胞胎产生于女性同时排出两个卵子，并分别由父亲的两个精子受精。所以这些双胞胎平均共享一半的基因，就像普通的兄弟姐妹一样。所以作为科学家，我们收集大量这两种类型的双胞胎，并比较它们在智力、性格、跑步速度、兴趣、食物偏好方面的相似性，在几乎我见过的每一项研究中，同卵双胞胎往往比异卵双胞胎更相似，
which suggests that the genes do play a role in the development of that trait. On the other hand, identical twins are never perfectly matched. There are always some differences. And so that becomes exciting because we can look to see what are those differences and how do we explain them? What environmental effects can we use? Now, twin studies are not just for twins. That's a very important point. Twin studies are a model. There were research paradigm for how we understand genetic and environmental influences on development in the population at large.
这表明基因确实在这些特征的发展中发挥了作用。另一方面，同卵双胞胎从来不是完全匹配的。总会有一些差异。所以这变得令人兴奋，因为我们可以观察这些差异是什么，以及我们如何解释它们？我们可以利用什么环境影响？现在，双胞胎研究不仅仅是为了双胞胎。这是一个非常重要的点。双胞胎研究是一个模型。它们是研究如何理解遗传和环境对人口中整体发展影响的研究范式。
So there have been hundreds of studies looking at this idea. What is this body of research tell us, Nancy, about things like personality and intelligence that things you just mentioned? Yes, well, there have been a lot of studies in both of those areas and we find that for intelligence, general ability, that that has about a 70 to 75% genetic influence. We find for personality close to 50%, but let me be clear about what those numbers mean. It does not mean say that for personality, I could take a person and slice their extra
所以已经有数百项研究关注这个想法。南希，这项研究告诉我们关于性格和智力等你刚才提到的事情的什么信息？是的，嗯，在这些领域已经有很多研究，我们发现对于智力、一般能力，它有大约70%到75%的遗传影响。我们发现性格接近50%，但让我明确一下这些数字意味着什么。这并不意味着，比如说对于性格，我可以把一个人的外向性或社交能力切分成遗传和环境成分。完全不是。这些在个体内部是完全交织在一起的。它确实意味着，如果我研究人口或群体中的性格，人与人之间会有差异，不是每个人都一样。大约一半的差异是由人与人之间的遗传差异解释的，大约一半的差异是由环境差异解释的。在某种程度上，你指出的是，对双胞胎研究意味着什么的肤浅理解
version or sociability into a genetic and environmental component. Not at all. Those are completely intertwined within individuals. What it does mean is that if I study personality in a population or a group, there's going to be variation from person to person, not everybody's the same. About half those differences are explained by the genetic differences among the people, and about half the differences were explained by environmental differences. In some ways, what you're pointing out is that the superficial take on what twin studies mean
实际上在描绘现实方面可能并不准确。我的意思是，当涉及到个体时，你的环境可以以深刻的方式塑造你成为什么样的人，就像你的基因可以以深刻的方式塑造你成为什么样的人一样。事实上，你研究过同卵双胞胎，他们有时因为从子宫里就开始的环境差异而变得非常不同。没错。我曾经研究过一对双胞胎，她们在七岁时身高相差四英寸，那是我研究她们的时候。在那起案例中发生的事情是，其中一个女孩，个子较矮的那个，有一个边缘附着的胎盘，这意味着她在产前没有获得足够的营养。
is actually perhaps not accurate in terms of depicting reality. I mean when it comes to individuals your environment can shape who you become in profound ways just like your genes can shape who you've become in profound ways. You've in fact studied identical twins who've turned out very different sometimes because of environmental differences that begin right in the womb. That's right. There was a pair of twins I studied once who differed in height by four inches when they were seven years old the time that I studied them. And what happened in that case was that one of the girls, the one who was shorter, had a marginally attached placenta, which means that she did not get enough nutrition prenatally.
当她们长大后，我第一次见到她们时感到震惊，因为她们看起来像彼此的同一个版本，只是一个非常小，一个非常大。然后当我回到她们年轻成年时期再次见到她们时，结果发现较高的双胞胎比另一个高出七英寸。所以这对这些仍然相同的基因产生了持久的影响。
As they grew up, I was shocked when I met them the first time because they look like the same version of each other, but just one very small and one very big. And then when I went back to see them again in their young adult years, it turned out that the taller twin was seven inches taller than the other one. So that was something that had a lasting imprint on these still identical genes.
对这些仍然相同的基因产生了持久的影响。子宫内的差异导致这对双胞胎看起来非常不同。同样，其他环境差异可以作用于拥有相同基因的两个人，并极大地重塑他们。这最好的例子之一可能是南希研究的波哥大双胞胎。考虑一下其中一个在错误家庭中长大的兄弟，威廉。他出生于城里的母亲，但在农场长大。即使作为一个小孩，他也很勤奋，喜欢学习。但他的环境限制了他的自然倾向。
lasting imprint on these still identical genes. Differences in the womb led these twins to look very different. Similarly, other environmental differences can act on two people with the same genes and reshape them dramatically. One of the best examples of this might be the Bogota twins that Nancy studied. Consider for example one of the brothers who grew up in the wrong home, William. He was born to the city mother, but raised on a farm. Even as a small child, he was studious and drawn to learning. But his circumstances put breaks on his natural inclinations.
南希说，他贫穷的农村地区的教育机会非常有限。它们不可用，所以他决定参军。在军队里，一旦你完成服役，你有权参加某种军官培训课程，这对威廉来说似乎很完美。那将是去上学，并由政府支付费用。但事实证明，不幸的是，当他在服役时，他感染了一种叫做利什曼病的疾病。虽然他从中恢复了，但这让他完全失去了机会。威廉通过军队获得教育的梦想
Opportunities for education in his poor farming village, Nancy says, were greatly limited. They were not available and so he decided to join the army. And in the army, once you complete your service, you are entitled to take some sort of officer's training course and that seemed perfect for William. It would have been going to school and being paid for by the government. But it turned out, unfortunately, that while he was in the service, he contracted a disease called Leshtmaniasis. And while he recovered from it, that put him completely out of the running. William's dream of getting an education
破灭了。当他发现自己身世的真相时，他已经辞职，不再接受正规教育。他开始在波哥大的肉铺工作。这时，他同卵双胞胎的同事碰巧路过这家店。随后的几年里发生的事情更揭示了环境重塑我们遗传继承的力量。对于威廉来说，他能选择的机会更少。那是他的麻烦，直到他来到波哥大。现在，威廉从那时起发生了什么
through the army was dashed. And by the time he discovered the truth about his origin, he had resigned himself to not getting a proper education. He had begun to work at the butcher shop in Bogota. This is when the co-worker of his identical twin happened to stop by the shop. What happened in the years that followed is even more revealing about the power of the environment to reshape our genetic inheritance. With William, there were just fewer opportunities he could even pick from. That was his trouble until he got down to Bogota. Now, what's happened to William since then
自从他见到他的兄弟豪尔赫以来，他现在已经在波哥大注册了法学院。他现在已经是第二年了，实际上是在卡洛斯的帮助下，卡洛斯在遗传或环境上与他没有关系，卡洛斯帮他研究了法学院，现在那是他寻求继续教育的地方。他有政治抱负。他想回到他长大的城镇，成为该镇的镇长。卡洛斯是另一个在错误家庭中长大的兄弟。
and since he's met his brother Jorge, he is now enrolled in law school in Bogota. He's in his second year of it now and with the help of Carlos, actually, who was not related to him genetically or environmentally, Carlos helped him research law schools, and now that's where he's looking to continue his education. He has political aspirations. He wants to go back to the town that he grew up in and become the mayor of the town. Carlos was the other brother who grew up in the wrong home.
他出生于农村地区的贫困家庭，但在波哥大长大。他的生活也因为住在城市而发生了巨大的重塑。卡洛斯是一名财务分析师，完成了大学学业和几个高级证书。他是一个非常时髦的人。他喜欢漂亮的衣服。他喜欢文化活动。
He was born to the poor family from a rural area but was raised in Bogota. His life, too, was dramatically reshaped by living in the city. Carlos is working as a financial analyst, having completed college and several advanced certificates. And he's very much a man about town. He loves nice clothes. He loves cultural activities.
很长一段时间里，他与威廉有很多麻烦，说，嗯，为什么威廉不这样做，为什么威廉不那样做？但他真的不明白根本没有机会，根本就没有。对于一个学术学科来说，双胞胎研究引起了极大的争议。关于其核心范式的辩论，即同卵双胞胎和异卵双胞胎之间的差异是由基因解释的。
And for a long time, he had a lot of trouble with William, saying, well, why didn't William do this, and why didn't William do that? But he really didn't understand that there were no opportunities that just weren't any. For an academic discipline, twin studies have drawn an extraordinary amount of controversy. There are debates about its central paradigm, which is that differences between identical twins and fraternal twins are explained by genes.
但如果家庭和老师对待同卵双胞胎的方式与对待异卵双胞胎的方式不同，那么群体之间的一些差异是否可能是由教养驱动的，而不是由先天驱动的。这些辩论背后隐藏着一种不安。如果基因决定了我们的智力和性格，这对我们在社会中看到的人与人之间的差异意味着什么？虽然我们已经看到在任何一个人身上将基因的影响与环境分开是不可能的，但通过指出他们的基因来解释人与人之间的差异是很诱人的。为什么一个人富有而另一个人贫穷？
But if families and teachers treat identical twins differently than they treat fraternal twins, could some of the differences between the groups be driven by upbringing, nother rather than nature. Underlying many of these debates is an unease. If genes determine our intelligence and personality, what does this say about differences we see in society between people? Although we've seen how it's impossible to separate the effect of genes from the environment in any person, it's tempting to explain differences between people by pointing to their genes. Why is one person rich and another poor?
基因。为什么我们在工作场所看到男人和女人之间的不同结果？基因，如果生物学解释了智力，为什么还要费心公共教育？毕竟，如果我们聪明，那是因为我们的基因，如果我们笨，那是因为我们的基因。我问南希她对这些论点有什么看法。嗯，那是对基因工作方式的真正误解。因为毕竟，行为是基因在环境中表达的函数。通过以不同方式调节或固定环境，你可以改变基因表达。现在有些行为比其他行为更难改变，但每个人都可以进步。
Genes. Why do we see different outcomes in the workplace between a man and a woman? Jeans, if biology explains intelligence, why bother with public education? After all, if we are smart, it's because of our genes, if we are dumb, it's because of our genes. I asked Nancy what she made of such arguments. Well, that's a real misunderstanding of the way that the genes work. Because after all, behavior is a function of genes being expressed in an environment. And by moderating or fixing the environment in different ways, you can alter gene expression. Now some behaviors are harder to alter than others, but everybody can improve.
每个人都可以发展新技能并变得更好。人们不可能都一样，我们并不都一样，我们不是一个巨大的同卵双胞胎，但每个人可能都有天赋、兴趣、各种各样的能力，这些能力未被发现，因为他们从未有机会表达它们。正如人们认为基因决定了我们生活的一切是错误的，那些说环境解释了一切的人也错过了一些关键的东西。我们所处的环境本身是由编码在我们基因中的倾向和习性所塑造的
Everybody can develop new skills and get better at that. People can't all be the same, we're not all the same, we're not all one big identical twin, but everybody probably has talents, interests, all kinds of abilities that are undiscovered because they've never had a chance to express them. Just as people are wrong in thinking that genes determine everything about our lives, those who say the environment explains everything are also missing something crucial. The environments we find ourselves in are themselves shaped by the proclivities and propensities
，特别是在涉及人类行为时，先天和后天确实是不可分割地交织在一起的。是的，完全正确。我们都选择环境中与我们相符的某些项目。所以虽然一个人可能被舞蹈课吸引，
that are encoded in our genes, especially when it comes to human behavior, nature and nurture really are inextricably intertwined. Yes, exactly. We all pick certain items in our environment that are compatible with who we are. And so while one person might be drawn to dance lessons,
一个人被音乐吸引，一个人被艺术吸引，这些就是意味着我们塑造我们环境的东西。所以环境在某种意义上是受基因影响的。然后在这些环境中，某些遗传倾向可能会被表达出来。所以从某种程度上说，我听到你说的，南希，我们的基因确实在塑造我们方面非常强大，但它们不一定是决定性的。说智力是可遗传的一回事，但当你说，你知道，你62.35%的智力来自你的基因，我们可能犯了虚假精确的错误。
one person to music, one person to art, these are the things that mean that we fashion our environment. So environments, in a sense, are genetically influenced. And then within those environments, certain genetic propensities might be expressed. So in some ways what I'm hearing you say in ANSI is that our genes indeed are very powerful in shaping us, but they are not necessarily deterministic. It's one thing to say that intelligence is heritable, but when you say, you know, 62.35% of your intelligence came from your genes, we might be guilty of false precision.
我同意这一点。我认为人们从这项研究中得到的一些最令人恐惧的事情是，一旦你有了你的基因，你就被它们困住了，这并不是真的。我们是做出决定我们将做什么、我们将多努力工作、我们将如何实现目标的人。毕竟，基因只是倾向，它们不是决定性的。我认为我们都可以为我们取得的成就感到巨大的自豪和快乐。
I agree with that. And I think that some of the thearest people have had from this research is that once you've got your genes, your stuck with them, and that's not really true. We are the ones who make decisions about what we will do, how hard we will work, how we will go about getting our goals. After all, genes are just propensities, they're not deterministic. I think that we can all take tremendous pride and happiness in those things that we accomplish.
我明白你自己有一个双胞胎。没错。我有一个异卵双胞胎妹妹安妮。我是大七分钟的姐姐，但我也是矮四英寸的妹妹。我们在人生观、外貌、天赋方面非常不同，但我们有很强的家庭忠诚度。我认为在我的家庭中，可能没有人像我爱我的妹妹那样爱别人。
I understand that you yourself have a twin. That's correct. I have a fraternal twin sister Anne. I'm the older twin by seven minutes, but I'm also the shorter twin by four inches. And we are very different in our outlooks, in our appearance, in our talents, but we have a lot of family loyalty. And I think there's probably no one I love as much in my family as my sister.
南希·西格尔是加州州立大学富勒顿分校的心理学教授，也是该双胞胎研究中心的主任。她是《意外的兄弟：出生时被交换的双胞胎的故事，以及先天与后天的力量》的作者。南希，感谢你今天参加《隐藏的大脑》。这绝对是一种荣幸。本集由劳拉·夸雷尔制作，塔拉·博伊尔和帕斯·沙编辑。我们的团队包括雷娜·科恩、珍妮·施密特和托马斯·刘。我们今天的无名英雄是路易斯·克莱门斯。
Nancy Segal is Professor of Psychology at California State University Fullerton and the director of that twin studies center. She is the author of accidental brothers, the story of twins exchanged at birth, and the power of nature and nurture. Nancy, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. It's been an absolute pleasure. This episode was produced by Laura Quarell and edited by Tara Boyle and Path Shah. Our team includes Raina Cohen, Jenny Schmidt and Thomas Liu. Our unsung hero today is Louise Clemens.
路易斯是NPR的一名编辑，他非常关心为年轻记者打开大门。我经常在早晨的自助餐厅看到他帮助实习生撰写求职信并为面试做准备。他是我们所有人如何通过给他们机会来帮助改变他人生活轨迹的活生生的提醒。路易斯在将我们自己的帕斯·沙带到《隐藏的大脑》中发挥了重要作用，现在我们无法想象没有他的生活会是什么样子。谢谢你，路易斯。
Louise is an editor at NPR and he cares deeply about opening doors for young journalists. I often see him in the cafeteria in the mornings helping interns craft cover letters and get ready for job interviews. He's a walking reminder of how we can all help change the trajectory of other people's lives by giving them opportunities. Louis played an important role in getting our very own part shot to Hidden Brain, where we now can't imagine what life was like before him. Thanks Louise.
欲了解更多《隐藏的大脑》，你可以在Facebook和Twitter上关注我们。如果你喜欢这一集，请告诉一位朋友，并帮助他们订阅我们的节目。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆，这是NPR。你这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。
For more Hidden Brain, you can follow us on Facebook and Twitter. If you liked this episode, please tell one friend about it and help them subscribe to our show. I'm Shankar Vidantum and this is NPR. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
想要了解更多Hidden Brain的内容，欢迎在Facebook和Twitter上关注我们。如果您喜欢这一集，请向一位朋友推荐，并帮助他们订阅我们的节目。我是Shankar Vidantum，这是NPR。目前这一集还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。